[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
I want to tell you what to think
about one thing the video
the YouTube video where you turn left to
right
turn left I thought we were talking
about eggs yeah the egg there was an egg
machine I thought you said you had an
egg machine I have an egg machine and I
didn't know if I should turn to the left
or to the right all right well I didn't
say you couldn't talk about YouTube
I think I just got nervous
dude you like a sitcom cat
and the whole five-year Arc would be do
you call it Rick's place and when can
Rick actually tolerate another human
being in his apartment
in a loving caring relationship and
there also he doesn't use them as a
podcast guest dude my dad did my dad we
got high and did those we did theoisms
on the bus God damn [__] where I grew up
we had two muskrats that fought a
squirrel and they got a guy got paid
five dollars to let you watch him he had
a hat made out of ten that cry was crazy
you know we got struck by lightning
twice get up bro [__] my dude dude
this is crazy man my my brother-in-law
and I didn't even have a sister but this
dude I knew next door to me used to eat
scrap metal for dinner for real what's
your best Asian well with Bobby I always
go like it's it's always a hyperbilized
version that's the joke it's like
whenever with him when he when I really
want to make him mad I go oh like it's
just it's so like like I'm starting up a
car
[Applause]
I couldn't be a real person and then
he's like that's super racist super
racist yeah yeah but also then on the
flight truth be told the one the the
flight attendant was this Asian woman
and she walked in the cockpit and I hear
her go what's going on up here and I'm
like come on come on how are the pilots
not
here he did the last live show with us
yeah and it was great and one of the
conversations we had on the live show
was the fact that you know each of us we
have foreign parents yeah you know their
accents are funny my mother's accent is
funny but I told Bobby and I think we
all agreed on this I don't know what it
is
but an Asian accent's always funnier
like and we can make fun of my mom and
her accent for days but she still sounds
if he pulls out his mom card and I'll be
like you win that's funny she's always
funnier well the internet loves
we were making fun of each other's moms
and for some reason it went like viral
that I just went cross-eyed and I was
like and the internet [__] loved it
I'll be honest with you yes please okay
yes did I say it right you close stop
there you go he's never gonna get it
yeah I got it he nailed it I'll never
try the last name though no it's not
that hard give me give me a shot hockey
is
[__] yes even still you say it
Stavros
he rolled the r wow
Korean tongue dude I can't do that
I have a face is that really yeah
[Laughter]
okay
yes no because I had to do it with my
lips slow down all right you can't you
can't roll your arms you do it
but I'm more like doing a gargoyle now
let me ask you this how do you is how
does that affect you eating [__] what
do you mean if you can't roll an R
that's not a good sign for how you eat
[__] I don't mean yeah no no I don't
want to start our relationship
yeah you're right you're right but you
know what you know how about this though
let me make it a car analogy okay please
some cars have faster stick shift right
at all
this guy hates cars
they have a faster uh would you say what
a faster what
happened
I can't wait to soup up my stick shift
let me try it let me try all right some
cards have stick shifts okay there you
go like a uh Mustang right sure sure
right yeah and some cars are automatic
they're a smart car right
right I'm just going to say yes
one car goes faster than the other right
but they both get there
[Laughter]
dude honestly
this weekend we're sitting at the bar me
and O'Connor this girl comes in and sits
behind him oh yeah and he's got his back
to her so he's facing me I can kind of
see her she's like
yeah hammered Gremlin dude she starts
she starts punching Chris
and he thinks like oh she's like yeah
we're having fun we're at the party he's
like okay he's knocking off and he like
went back to be like come on yeah above
above the way cut it out we're goofing
and she was like get your [__] hands
off me you piece of [__] and I was like
dude we gotta move yeah we gotta get the
[__] out of here and then she kept doing
it she started like actually like
pushing him like I could see him like
push moving and I was like hey could you
please
like stop hitting my friend yeah and she
goes you're fat
it's just like God damn it lady
dude she goes yo she goes you're fat and
then she goes
hold her tube top down put out her tits
she's wearing a tube top yeah she went
Jesus Christ pulled out big fat boobs
and ladies she's not been so mean to me
I wouldn't have been mean back but she
was like you're fat pulled her tits and
I was like your tits are [__]
disgusting dude those are disgusting you
gross idiot and she was like yeah I am
ugly and I was immediately I was like no
you're not I'm sorry like she was like
so sad but then she was like yeah I'm
ugly I was like no you're not and she
was like but you're fat so who cares and
I was like well okay
[__] you
oh you talk about a girl misfunction
just pushing boys pulling your tits out
it's like it was I'm ugly I'm ugly
yeah go get it like she couldn't even
see me hit me with the year I was like
damn she's hit me with like you're fat
from like me sitting she could just see
like tear up she was just like you're
[__] fat I was like Jesus Christ God
damn didn't you see the whole of me and
then we keep going we go back to talking
she's just
at the bar she takes her [__] beer
just turns it upside down puts it back
and sits there a bartender comes over
one of the [__] dudes came over and
kissed her
he like came over to be like hey how are
you doing she was like and he kissed he
kissed on the lips it was a peck on the
lips whoa I was like okay all right to
be fair that bartender was probably on
coke definitely to be fair that guy was
probably she pours the beer out
he's she's just sitting there now a guy
comes over and he's like did you spill
this and she was like no
it's like I was like [__] you gotta get
her the [__] out of here yeah dude that
should be a police escort for a girl
that drunk to get home it's like she was
still outside when we left we were
leaving she was outside I was like geez
dude somebody should help not me though
someone could help her
I'm a Good Samaritan I'm not a fat
Samaritan you call me fat
you ever read that book
that book about the six right so you
read that book it's wild how like these
people who are in your you know the book
chaos it's about it's basically about
Charles Manson and the Manson Murders
but also how MK Ultra kind of that mind
experiment stuff they some people really
believe that he was just a government
psyop and and his mind was even though
he didn't do anything he it was all like
manip controlling like because these
some of the people who were the
murderers they were like not like that
before they just snapped yeah so and and
all these Hollywood people were involved
like who was it like the woman from The
Mamas and the Papas that singer was I
good friends with him
um you know all the Roman Polanski [__]
was weird it's very very I've only read
three chapters I'm talking like I know
the book that's great that's what I do
with everything yeah I'm like yeah I
kind of know something and I'm like let
me go on record yeah I'm always
preparing for Rogan just reading a
chapter or two oh that's crazy what else
and you're like I don't know you gotta
Jamie bring it up yeah yeah
no I don't [__] know dude you're so
good at fighting and I'm so not yeah
I've never seen a chimp play with devil
sticks you gotta go do it bring it the
[__] up yeah I'm such a stoner that all
the videos he recommends I'm usually
like I do want to see that yeah let me
ask you this if you were at a baseball
game and you were in the Outfield
and a home run came your way I'm
literally in the Outfield
you're playing Left Field what happened
oh my God I gotta get my glove nope no
glove oh no no no no and you're wearing
a suit what the [__] uh if you were out
in the stands in the Outfield a home run
came your way you got the Home Run do
you keep that ball or do you give it to
a little kid
uh who hit it uh
oh that's a that's not a great answer
yeah you gotta give it to the little kid
oh fine in your made-up hypothetical yes
not only do I give it to the child but I
take that child and adopt him will you
keep a judge's home run uh if you would
have caught that
yeah yes I'll buy the kid like an uh you
know a bicycle or something
get him an ice cream season tickets
that's a tough spot I know you're a big
baseball fan uh hmm and so we were at
the World Series this year yeah oh wow
yeah that was all right boy I hated that
team got thrown out for the Phillies oh
yeah really yeah well over the Astros no
no I hate the astross I respect both
teams I respect them but uh how'd you
hate the fills this year they're a
hateable team I don't think yeah they're
not that's all we have here today folks
and the fans are kind of douchey too
you're talking about us right now yeah
and they don't dress well
the one's ball the other one's fatty
[__] that's just what I heard other fans
so you know how old white people love to
shake hands they do they don't they it's
their whole thing right but did did
white people invented shaking hands
it's a good point because I think Asians
of bow yeah yeah yeah oh yeah right but
do you think white people went hello sir
I think so yeah yeah wait who who came
up with mouth kissing like like french
kissing I mean me and my brother
all I wanted was to like you I wanted
the business I was like how the [__] do
I get on how do I get another how do I
get to this thing how do I get I was so
concerned were you married back then no
dude no no no six years ago
psycho nah dudes dudes and chicks no not
dudes you wouldn't hook up a dude you
ever kissed a guy actually in any
capacity okay for a roll 2023 you know
[__] come on no would you would you
would you go game for a role
here's the funny thing no
Tim what was your favorite memory of
2022 my friend
oh God I liked the
um invasion of Ukraine
because it was exciting it was exciting
um it was like Willy Wonky Willy
Willy I just like
um spontaneity
well he's stole mine
Josh tell us about your life what do you
do for work I sell beef jerky
carne seca I gotta make a living dude
comedy doesn't pay
how do you sell beef jerky I sell at the
flea markets and at uh farmers markets
wow this is incredible wow the crowd's
going wild I think you've been
recognized nine years in comedy you're
recognized more for your beef jerky than
you are
for any jokes incredible uh how often do
you do it uh to sell to be of turkey no
stand up
[Applause]
[Music]
that we're doing right now
every night
you do stand up every night I try to
come out every night I live very far so
I go out on the open mic so yeah it's
tough isn't it what's tougher stand up
or your beef jerky beef jerky
that's harder to sell [__] yeah at least
at the Mexican restaurants they come
ready to eat sauce right yeah that beef
jerky sounds tough
yeah yeah that's the joke I made 25
seconds ago yeah I did you missed it you
were too busy cooking up that tough beef
jerky joke you didn't notice that I did
it
that yours came out dehydrated as hell
it's very dry very dry yeah absolutely
absolutely what's drier beef jerky or
women's [__] when you're around them
I audition for something in La this is
years ago and I was supposed to be it
was me and an old guy and I was reading
a script and we were watching a football
game as my dad and he dies next to me
right and they were like all right go
action and I was like oh look daddy
caught the he caught the touchdown and
he's like you know and I'm like ah
I mean this is crazy and they they were
like get out they just they weren't even
they didn't even think it was cute or
anything they said please leave you
reacting to a real emotional is just
pure comedy I know
I'm a comedian I don't know what to do
oh [__] he's dead oh [__] what they set
me right out of there I drove like Santa
Monica yeah Dad that was it probably the
negatives of Texas I'm saying despite
the negatives despite them you gotta
take texting over phone calls despite
them I'm not arguing against the
negatives I'm just saying it doesn't
[__] matter it's like saying despite
the arguments of land mines
don't pick up the [__] phone I'm not
getting on the phone with that guy I
can't get off the phone they Yap all the
time what about being like I sent three
words to someone and I said oh I need to
say to them and I go all my day what
about the point of I can't remember this
[__] person I don't want to get on
the phone with them thank God but it's
but it's not Jesus but it's never that
it's never I said three words in your
head it is it's not that though it's
it's bro we got we got it down to a
thumb we got it down we're going back to
hieroglyphics now okay that's how we
communicate I could send someone a thumb
and I tell them what I need to tell them
instead of going seven
two seven five six eight five five hello
it sounds good to me all right we gotta
go to this I send a thumb I send a thumb
all parties know yeah that's a lot
easier than pressing a person's name how
about group text people live nothing I
hate worse we live on group text do you
think that every time we have to talk
the four of us had to get on a party
line and talk to each other about it I
don't know we have to talk as much as we
ever do I I think you don't
if the four of us had to get on a call
every time we had to book something you
would rip your dick off okay you texting
has positives too
texting you can't go a whole week
without text this is the I rest my in
the world we live in of course I can't
you can't go the whole week without a
phone call what the [__] yes I can I
can do it that's very one-sided and
privileged W then I don't know what else
to say what what are you talking about
that's a nice place to live in that you
can go tough [__] if you don't like my
texting I don't have that [__]
Advantage I have to you'll never have
that Advantage because you don't think
highly enough of yourself
my point is is is I would say this the
fight we got into that you referenced
first no I didn't know I referenced
something general and you took it to
mean that specific thing when I can tell
you to your face right now that's not
what I meant but you won't believe me
but you just gotta but let's talk about
what just happened you got the building
in trouble no we both use you were
yelling first now what are you talking
about Joe and you said that it was
personal and I was like ah [__] all
right here we are well I think it was
personal I just thought it was weird
that you bring up one specific fight
when I'm just talking about text
messaging I I know I thought I was only
I thought you were we already talked I
thought you said I was all right by that
I thought you were hanging up the fight
I should hug well this is uh this is the
Hallmarks the Hallmarks of a strong
friendship moments ago they were we were
swinging from the rafters right now
we're calmly talking it out
it's all good I think it came full
circle I think it shows how what strong
of a bond we actually have
I think it's guaranteed Joe kills
himself tonight
send a note via text
yeah
there was this friend of mine Seth I
think his name's Seth I haven't talked
to him since high school okay but he had
cancer in high school okay not Hodgkin's
lymphoma so it's pretty chill I think it
is of cancer it is when someone gets a
really treatable one and really milks it
it's like no it's great though because
we were in high school so he milked it
by being able to smoke weed and be high
in school and then we'd go to his house
after and he'd have like really good
weeds you know he really lucked out that
a friend got cancer bald homie yeah and
yeah every time I just I was like I'm
gonna die and Seth I was like no I'm
good
I was like I swear I'm dying right now
and he's like I have chemo tomorrow yeah
okay okay I mean I think this is
probably a narcissistic thing to say but
don't you once
someone dies like I remember the first
person I knew that died because it was
Scott and we were in uh College he got
hit by a car
and [__] yeah and right on in front of
the bar we were all at and drunk yeah he
was and we used to cross the street just
run across the street and he just went
to turn run across the street and the
car hit him and that was it and I
remember thinking
but I'm I'm still here like that's crazy
that he's gone and I'm here yeah it's
[__] weird it's almost like in a
weird way like a
schadenfreude Jordan Freud that's it
we're like people die but then you stay
yeah and you're like [__] so I guess I
always live
right right because you have lived yeah
and I keep I keep missing it like you
know yeah yeah but it's like so every
time someone dies I go another one man
you're right so every time somebody dies
it's it's really about your survival
it's really just another sign that
you're never gonna die
something
that's I don't think that's narcissistic
it's it's just [__]
and now time for some podcasting stats
to end this video real quick Andrew
Santino made the most guest appearances
this month going on an incredible eight
total podcast including flagrant kill
Tony the blocks podcast with Neil
Brennan you know what dude your mom's
house breaking bread with Tom Papa
impulsive and pardon my take the most
viewed episode from last month is the
two bears one Cave episode featuring Tom
Segura and Dr Andrew huberman that was
posted on January 16th 2023 and
currently sits at a whopping 2.6 million
views other than that thank you so much
for watching this video and being part
of the fastest growing community of
Comedy fans on the internet and in the
world it's very sick if you love comedy
this is a channel for you the sports
center of Comedy that's why we're
reading you the stats
um also shout out to my guy Ted munz at
tedman's mosaic art on Instagram he
makes his dope joke World sign go check
out his Instagram if you like art and
comedy and podcast signs other than that
I'll see you Monday with the comedy news
foreign
[Music]